[Music]
2008 of the the Republican big
Republican presidential candidates they
were asked how many of you believe in in
Darwinian biological evolution
two-thirds or three-quarters said I do
2012 same question asked same group of
people Republican presidential
candidates it was already down to a
third 2016 the 17 people main candidates
for the Republican nomination asked do
you believe in evolution one Jeb Bush
brave Jeb Bush said he did but he said
walking it back even as he said it I'm
not sure should be taught in our public
schools and if it is it should be taught
along with creationism so from 2008 to
2016 that was the change and that
changes I don't believe all those people
believed what they said I don't think
all of them disbelieve in evolution some
of them but they were all obliged to to
say yes to to falsehood and magical
thinking of this religious kind and and
that's where it becomes problematic
America has always been a Christian
nation that meant a very different thing
100 years ago or even 50 years ago than
it means today I grew up not going to
church very often at all and not with
much religious education but all of my
friends were weekly regular churchgoers
of various kind Christian Protestant
religion became extreme became more
magical and supernatural in its beliefs
and practices in America then then it
had been in hundreds of years and and
and more so than it is anywhere else in
the developed world so you have that
happening at the same time not
coincidentally you have the Republican
Party beginning certainly by 30 years
ago becoming more and more a party of
those religiously extreme Protestants so
it one thing that has happened and one
thing that
has led I think the Republican Party to
accept fantasy and and and and wishful
untruth more and more into its approach
to policy whether its climate change or
or or the idea that secret Muslim
conspiracy is about to replace our
constitutional judiciary system with
Sharia law or or any number of other
simply untrue tenets of republicanism
all these things which were nutty fringe
ideas as recently as thirty years ago
are now in the Republican mainstream I
think there's a connection I think once
you have a political party more and more
of whose members are believed in in in
religious and supernatural fantasies of
a more and more extravagant kind it it
stands to reason or to unreason that how
you will have a party that is more and
more inclined to embrace the fantastical
in its politics and policy believe
whatever you want in the privacy of your
home the privacy of your family in the
privacy of your church but when it
bleeds over as it inevitably has done in
America to how we manage and construct
our economy and our society and we're in
trouble
[Music]
you